suppose that men have a mean height of
178 centimeters with a standard
deviation of 8 centimeters women have a
mean height of 170 centimeters with a
standard deviation of 6 centimeters the
male and female heights are each
normally distributed we independently
randomly select a man and a woman what
is the probability that the woman is
taller than the man so I encourage you
to pause this video and think through it
and I'll give you a hint what if we were
to define the random variable M as equal
to the height of a randomly selected man
height of random man what if we define
the random variable W to be equal to the
height of a random woman woman and we
defined a third random variable in terms
of these first two so let me call this D
for difference and it is equal to the
difference in height between a randomly
selected man and a randomly selected
woman so d the random variable D is
equal to the random variable M minus the
random variable W so the first two are
clearly normally distributed they tell
us that right over here the male and
female Heights are each normally
distributed and we also know or you're
about to know that the difference of
random variables that are each normally
distributed is also going to be normally
distributed
so given this can you think about how to
tackle this question the probability
that the woman is taller than the man
all right now let's work through this
together and to help us visualize I'll
draw the normal distribution curves for
these three random variables so this
first one is for the variable M and so
right here in the middle that is the
mean of M and we know that this is going
to be equal to 178 centimeters we'll
assume everything is in centimeters
we also know that it has a standard
deviation of 8 centimeters so for
example this is one standard deviation
above this is one standard deviation
below this point right over here would
be 8 centimeters more than 178 so that
would be 186 and this would be 8
centimeters below that so this would be
170 centimeters so this is for the
random variable M now let's think about
the random variable W the random
variable W the mean of W they tell us is
170 and one standard deviation above the
mean is going to be 6 centimeters above
the mean the standard deviation is 6 6
centimeters
so this would be minus 6 is to go to one
standard deviation below the mean now
let's think about the difference between
the two the random variable D so let me
think about this a little bit the random
variable D the mean of D is going to be
equal to the differences in the means of
these random variables so it's going to
be equal to the mean of M the mean of M
minus the mean of W minus the mean of W
well we know both of these this is going
to be 178 minus 170 so let me write that
down
this is equal to 178 centimeters minus
170 centimeters which is going to be
equal to I'll do it in this color this
is going to be equal to 8 centimeters so
this is 8 right over here now what about
the standard deviation assuming these
two random variables are independent and
they tell us that we are independently
randomly selecting a man and a woman the
height of the man shouldn't affect the
height of the woman or vice versa
assuming that these two are independent
variables if you take the sum or the
difference of these then the spread will
increase but you won't just add the
standard deviations what you would
actually do is say the variance of the
difference is going to be the sum of
these two variances so let me write that
down
so I could write vary
ins with var or I could write it as a
standard deviation squared so let me
write that the standard deviation of D
of our difference squared which is the
variance is going to be equal to the
variance of our variable M plus the
variance of our variable W now this
might be a little bit counterintuitive
this might have made sense to you if
this was plus right over here but it
doesn't matter if we are adding or
subtracting and these are truly
independent variables then regardless of
whether we're adding or subtracting you
would add the variances and so we can
figure this out this is going to be
equal to the standard deviation of
variable m is 8 so 8 squared is going to
be 64 and then we have 6 squared this
right over here is 6 6 squared is going
to be 36 you add these two together this
is going to be equal to 100 and so the
variance of this distribution right over
here is going to be equal to 100 well
what's the standard deviation of that
distribution what's going to be equal to
the square root of the variance so the
square root of 100 which is equal to 10
so for example one standard deviation
above the mean is going to be 18 one
standard deviation below the mean is
going to be equal to negative 2 and so
now using this distribution we can
actually answer this question what is
the probability that the woman is taller
than the man well we can rewrite that
question is saying what is the
probability that the random variable D
is what conditions would it be pause the
video and think about it
well the situations where the woman is
taller than the man if the woman is
taller than the man then this is going
to be a negative value then D is going
to be less than zero so what we really
want to do is figure out the probability
that D is less than zero and so what we
want to do if we say zero is right over
if we said that zero is
right over here on our distribution so
that is d is equal to zero we want to
figure out well what is the area under
the curve less than that so we want to
figure out this entire area there's a
couple of ways you could do this you
could figure out the z-score for D
equaling zero and that's pretty
straightforward you could just say this
Z is equal to zero minus our mean of 8
divided by our standard deviation of 10
so it's negative 8 over 10 which is
equal to negative 8/10 so you could look
up a Z table and say what is the total
area under the curve below Z is equal to
negative 0.8 another way you could do
this is you could use a graphing
calculator I have a ti-84 here where you
have a normal cumulative distribution
function
I'm going to press 2nd vars and that
gets me to distribution and so I have
these various functions I want normal
cumulative distribution function so that
is choice two and then the lower bound
well I want to go to negative infinity
well calculators don't have a negative
infinity button but you could put in a
very very very very negative number that
for our birth business is equivalent to
negative infinity so we could say
negative 1 times 10 to the 99th power
and the way we do that is second this to
capital ease or saying essentially times
10 to the and I'll say 99 power so this
is a very very very negative number the
upper bound here we want to go let me
delete this the upper bound is going to
be 0 we're finding the area from
negative infinity all the way to 0 the
mean here well we've already figured
that out the mean is 8 and then the
standard deviation here we figured this
out too this is equal to 10 and so when
we pick this we're going to go back to
the main screen enter so this is we
could have just typed this in directly
on the main screen this says look we're
looking at a normal distribution we want
to find the cumulative area between two
bounds in this case is from negative
infinity to 0 from negative infinity to
0 where the mean is 8 and the standard
deviation is 10 we press enter and we
get approximately zero point two one two
is approximately zero point two one two
or you could say what is the probability
that the woman is taller than the man
well zero point two one two or
approximately there's a twenty one point
two percent chance of that happening a
little better than one in five